let's talk about models
models like linear regression
weather models which are in fact models
sitting on top of models which sit on
top of differential equations sitting on
top of blah blah blah
models like large language models heck
this is actually a flow chart so this is
a model of a model and of course this is
something that's creating a lot of
consternation in our industry right now
and models like this authored model of
an EMD sd40-2 from Milwaukee Road in
1972. wait Peter that's not a model like
we do heck yeah it is
models are an imitation of the real
thing and the models that we train every
day and the models that model
railroaders play with and the models
that DND people play their RPGs with are
all the same damn thing they're all
classes of the same super type of models
you might not have ever thought that
thought but that's because we data
scientists are a bit of a haughty brunch
Bunch I'm hungry brunch Bunch
um
just a few years ago we were the sexiest
job of the 21st century DJ Patel keynote
talk plugging this
when you're a speaker plugging the other
speakers is a key skill
we're not the only people who get to
play in the data sandbox anymore our
industry is undergoing maturation there
are all sorts of other data jobs see the
other tracks at this conference we are
now playing with other model Builders
who are calling themselves decision
scientists we have storytellers all the
different analysts jobs we have code
builders in the form of mles and as a
horrible horrible coder myself I think
God every day that we have people who I
can blame for coding problems I mean uh
work with me
um these days we have machines that can
do a lot of the mechanistic stuff that
we have drilled down for a decade and a
half on it very heavily as an industry
they can do those things for us so
what's left for us as data scientists
you know when we get out ahead of
ourselves we give an AI winter in the 60
years of our industry and yes we are a
60 year old industry at this point we
think we're very young we've been around
a while we've had two AI Winters and
this boom that we are in right now is
the biggest boom that our industry has
ever been in it's been long it's been
really really good for all of us and I
don't think any of us want it to end
because our paychecks depend on it
complete aside no this wasn't a planned
thing I was talking to someone during
the last break downstairs and she told
me the definition of prosperity is when
the booms get so close together you
don't notice the winters and I thought
that was really profound and I want to
share that right now cool thought you
know
we data scientists are quantitative
thinkers
by the way that last talk very
quantitative this one there will be zero
equations if I can get away with it
there'll be very few with text period
um we can look at all sorts of things we
like to think in analogies so let's go
back to those model Builders those model
railroaders right
what were they doing when they were 60
years old where did their world go to if
we can take a look at where other people
who have thought about the world as a
symbol crumb take a look at where they
go maybe we can see what's going on
beyond the end of this timeline here
um and why should you trust me in my
ill-fitting code up here well one I'm up
here and you're not
um thank you Chevy Chase uh that would
be a good joke
um two because I am a geography and data
scientist I've been running DS teams for
many years now multiple companies
um and three because I have been a Model
Railroader my entire life my dad is a
modeler my brother is a Model Railroader
and God willing I'll get my son to be a
modeler order too
um so I think thinking about models
pretty much my whole life in very very
different ways between when I am home in
the basement and when I am at work at my
desk which actually for the last couple
years is the exact same place
um mono Rarity when it was 60 years old
was a very similar place to DS today so
model Rarity starts out in the 1880s
with these things called carpet
dribblers they're copper in brass toys
for kids in Kid Likes adults you fill
them with water you put fire underneath
because in the 1880s fire was an
appropriate kid toy
um and you let them run across the
carpet and they're called carpet
dribblers they dripped water and oil and
set fire to carpets cool
in the early 1900s electricity comes
into play and we have electric trains
they are still four kids they are a toy
um and the early part of the 1900s being
where they are they are all very white
people males in these uh pictures I
really tried hard to find a woman in one
of them and I could not do it sorry I
did try
um
people are playing with themselves toys
they take the track goes around the
living room it goes attached to some
plywood it's doing stuff it's not the
carpet dribbler that ran randomly and
said fires things but it's still a toy
60 years in the mid-1940s World War II
has just ended
the gis are coming home they have
basements for the first time in Suburbia
and they're filling them with trains
um it's the biggest Hobby in the United
States of America it's something which
people don't think about these days
um and people want to go beyond just
being toys kind of like data science
going from good old-fashioned AI that
barely works on to machine learning that
works a lot better to AI which is now
eating the world although I I personally
hate the phrase AI
um one of the first people who thought
about this was a guy named Frank Ellison
he says we're going to stop being a toy
trains and start being the art of model
railroading we're going to go beyond
this we're going to have your railroad
which is in model Rarity speak the
layout the scenery the track all the
stuff
um in our world we call that a model by
the way
um we're going to make that be a stage
the trains are the actors on that stage
they run through it and they're going to
have jobs they're not just going around
in circles for no reason they're going
to have actual reasons and he goes down
he goes to this very elaborate analogy
over multiple Parts in his Series in his
analogy is theater
I say the analogy this day should be
data science things what we're doing
that layout is a model of the world the
trains that are on it are actors moving
through it that are programmed in
different ways of course he's not using
Code he's writing
diagrams like this so walking away from
the microphone sorry
you can see here
he's railroad as a block diagram at the
bottom we have different trains those
trains all have different jobs and names
the local passenger train the Manifest
Freight the local switcher they meet at
different places along this at different
points in the schedule he's programming
a diagram a graph if you will the nodes
are the stations in the sightings and
everybody's meeting up and following
their their instructions you are an
engineer you're playing an engineer just
like you were in some D and D game or
something like that you're an engineer
you're a dispatcher you're a yard Master
you are running the passenger trade
you're following rules and you are
running a railroad this is a very
different way of thinking about things
he's building a model
it's a physical model but it's still a
model
on the other end
of these world of making model Rarity
more serious is John Allen and he builds
a railroad called the gorion defeated in
Monterey California he's friends with
all sorts of folks from Walt Disney so
there's imagineers who are working on
this railroad there's early folks coming
in from Silicon Valley some Intel
Founders actually were involved with
this at some point and they're all
building this railroad together but the
point is not to be realistic it's to be
this Epic
sort of world that's new that didn't
exist in the real world
you can walk into this the the sceneries
floor to ceiling it's all over the place
there's a train in here can you even see
it it's out there in the middle it's
besides the point the point is the
entire world that's built around this
the trains are doing not as
sophisticated things as Frank Ellison
his world is whatever we've got a
railroad that's besides the point the
trains things are doing things here the
environment is important oh yeah what
the hell does this mean Peter you're
showing me pretty pictures of trains
we're data scientists oh yeah let's
bring it back to our world
Frank Ellison is very much so in the
vein of folks who want to build simple
crumbs of the world actor models things
like that whereas Frank Allison he wants
to throw everything at you and let the
machine forget you experience pick the
part that you want that's like a large
language model what's going on here is
they're thinking about rural Space
Systems versus creative based systems
they want to come up with different ways
of experiencing the world
that don't exist that are like the world
but a lot smaller than it that's data
science in a nutshell so
with that first section done why I think
this is a good analogy for data science
and where we're going let's go and take
a look at some of the thoughts
from model Rarity at this period
and take them back to data science and
see how we can think about models
differently how we can apply those
lessons to what we're doing today
so you know this one was hard to
visualize because I resorted to text and
I never do that
the 10-foot rule is this idea if
something looks good at 10 feet it's
probably good enough we call this
overfitting in our world this idea of
drilling down to something to a level of
detail that's Way Beyond what you need
um and this is also not just a problem
in training models I think this is an
overall problem with
um data science as a whole you read
papers coming out of kdd or neural IPS
and a good third to a quarter you know
quarter to third of them are going to be
I've increased the accuracy on some
Benchmark model by you know two decimal
points big whoop
um it's so what we need what we need is
pop things that solve big problems not
little problems anyway
I digress
the 10 foot rule
when we are in model railroading world
we talk about the Prototype the real
thing in data science we talk about
ground truth or training data this is
training data for a Model Railroader
this is a real train not a model I wish
I was that good
um this is a specific engine
um that runs on Canadian national it's
an EMD gp38-2 and I don't know this I
actually had to ask my brother he's much
better at this than I am
um I just say it's a train specific
thing it's got a special paint Scheme so
it's the only one that has this paint
scheme
here's a model of that train it's made
by a company called Rapido and Rapido is
very very drilled in on the details so
the paint is the exact same shade as the
real thing it has the paint Scheme it
has the exact windshield wiper that that
particular model has because apparently
the one on the right is different than
the one on the left and people who buy
these types of models care about those
things
um here's another model of unit 6401
it's got a wee bit less detail but it's
still clearly the same thing
now we and we do things in data science
we tend to try and focus in on the
details but this is just a way of
showing us that it doesn't really matter
to get that dealed in you can go way
farther out and still have the important
stuff about something it's a Continuum
when we're building models it's not just
to you know maximize accuracy or you
know recall a 10 or what have you we our
job in a world where there are lots of
people playing in the data sandbox
data scientists are supposed to be the
coordinators we're not supposed to be
the ones actually building the models
that's what decision scientists are for
we're not supposed to be the ones right
in the code that's what machine learning
Engineers are for we're not telling
ultimately the stories to the clients
that's what analysts are for so what's
left for us our job is to think about
the data to think about the models the
trains to think about the data that goes
into those models the layouts the things
that are around them our job is to be
the coordinators to be closer to artists
than to technicians
um and I probably should have hit the
button that shows data science when I
said that
um
but even if you go all the way drill in
on those High Fidelity models from
Rapido or companies like that there's
compromises that are being made our
decisions as data scientists are to
manage those
uh compromises just like someone on Wall
Street is a risk analysis analyst their
job is to think about all of the things
that can go wrong that impact things we
should be the folks who are thinking
about all the things that go into Data
not just I happen to have a file and
these are the things that are in it here
are the correlates to the things that
are in it here are all of the things
that it could connect to we need to
become managers of data because this
model is not the real thing ultimately
somewhere it had to make a compromise
it's powered by an electric motor not a
2 000 horsepower diesel engine it's
ultimately not really the real thing
it's a model it's an imitation all of
our models are imitations all of our
models are compromised we hear this
phrase when we're learning first about
models and then we probably never think
about it again again and that phrase is
all models
are broken but some are useful right
ultimately all of our models are not
really representing the real world our
job is to become the compromise managers
of those things
so in model railroading there are lots
of different scales G scale which is
what I model big big chunky trains in
fact so big they won't fit in my house
they are in my garden
um my brother he models HO trains a lot
smaller fit inside his basement so is my
dad
um it's a common choice to pick a
smaller thing because they have a
smaller space
um
part of that compromise management that
we're going to have to be doing in the
future as data scientists is to making
the same choices that a model railroad
or would when they're picking their
scale now you maybe you make your choice
based off of your available space my
brother has a big basement so he can put
that HO train in it
um
but what if you have lots of space and
the thing is that what you what you
really are interested in is the
mechanics right well you can go big this
is called live steam it's the biggest
model railroading scale this is a steam
engine right it's got a fire inside it's
just like that carpet dribbler hopefully
not setting anyone on fire
um that boiler is filled with water
there are fire tubes fires going through
those tubes it's boiling the water it's
turning Pistons this is as close as you
can get to the real thing this is the
highest Fidelity model you can build
right well you still have to have
compromises this train Mountain it's the
biggest private railroad I believe in
the United States and possibly the world
and to have those big live steam models
it covers square miles this is the model
railroading equivalent of having a high
performance Computing cluster this is a
super computer of trains
um they're expensive they're big that is
a compromise that someone had to choose
to do I want the big thing not I have to
fit it inside the space that I have
available if you don't make that
compromise you end up with something
like this this is the Cadbury railroad
it's I believe in Wales
um and this is it so the Reverend Teddy
Boston who built this was able to get a
real Narrow Gauge steam locomotive and a
car two cars this is this is the entire
Road extends about five feet on either
side of this photo
he was not willing to compromise on size
at all so he had to compromise on his
environment in other words it's always a
compromise even if you think you aren't
making a compromise in your data by
drilling down and being having as many
features as possible you are also making
a decision to eliminate all the things
outside of it there is no happy median
everything that we do is in some way
going to break from the real thing this
isn't a equation that can be solved
unfortunately I know everything in data
science is ultimately some kind of
optimization problem but this is one
that there is no equation because it is
a human problem it is a problem of
resources it's a problem of the things
that you have available in front of you
and it is ultimately a political problem
because we all work for people and all
those people are telling us to get
done faster
um and you only have these many
resources to do it with
everything is a compromise most of our
environments probably look less like
this because as far as I can tell this
is the only one in its kind in the world
and more like this so this is Z scale
this is the smallest practical model
rarerating scale and with this I could
build a whole Railroad in a briefcase I
wouldn't but maybe somebody else would
who wants to now you're talking a train
that is 20 feet long in live steam fits
on your pinky finger
now that's a compromise that you have to
choose compromise I keep saying this
it's almost like it's the theme that I
want you to walk out of here with Crazy
um maybe your compromise goes in a
different way you love big modern trains
that can be up to two miles long well
you have little tiny trains but a big
basement and that means that I can now
go with the length with higher Fidelity
than I can with the individual models
again we need to be thinking about the
things that go into our models if the
trains are
individual rows of data with features in
the layouts are the models
then we need to be the people who are
making the artistic choices of what goes
into them like I said these are
optimization problems but they're not
solvable ones that's why you need data
scientists this is a call to arms that
this is where our industry is going to
be going
there's lots of things out there that
are going to be replacing the drudgery
and if you replace the drudgery you'll
end up with the art we have to rise to
that
so let's take a look at one last thing
and again I couldn't find a good photo
so we had to resort to text I consider
every Tech slide in the Peter lens
presentation to be a failure
this is the hatch B loop it's a very
famous place in American railroading
because one of the very few places where
we have a spiral a place where train
crosses over itself so there's lots of
people who want to model this
and here's somebody who did in N scale
not quite as small as Z but pretty dang
small and they've gone all out to
recreate it that house is really exactly
right there it's the same size as the
real one the train crosses it over over
itself these are the right types of cars
for the error this is really realistic
but even then compromises for example in
reality no fluorescent lighting on the
ceiling no hovering exit sign in the
background you can go really really deep
but you can't go 100 percent
this is called prototype modeling and
this is actually mentally where a lot of
data science is today we take our data
and we recreate it inside of a model
Jack Burgess is kind of the dean of this
kind of thinking in the U.S
um and he models not just a specific
railroad but a specific Railroad on a
specific day in a specific year the
Yosemite Valley Railroad uh near the end
of its life and this is his Railroad on
the uh one side and on the other side is
the exact same photo from real life he's
got the exact same cars as they existed
if there's a plank missing he pulls that
plank off you can tell they're different
because in this photo you can see
right on up the Merced Valley up into
Yosemite Valley and on his well that
ends because he has a wall there you
know real life has walls that get in the
way of your monover road you have to
curve around them
um
I really like this particular one
because that Tall Tree there on the hill
is Right Where I lived when I worked for
the National Park Service
um at the other end of scale is complete
creativity freelancing this is rolling
element He made trains that have no
basis in reality they are made up
um
there's no tradition like this in data
science we have toy data our toy data
sets are still based off of reality but
there's still a lesson that we can learn
here by blending the two ideas prototype
plus freelancing equals prototype
freelancing it's a very creative name I
have to admit
um this is The Virginian in Ohio it's a
monorail that's built by a man
um Alan McClellan who unfortunately
passed last year
um
The Virginian in Ohio first off he has a
Wikipedia page I don't know how many
model rails have Wikipedia pages but
this one has one and it has a history it
has maps that are real maps and the
routes go through real valleys and we
serve real towns and real Minds the
trains that run along it they have real
Connections in the real world it's
freelanced it's made up but it's rooted
in real life hey that sounds like a data
science idea oh right synthetic data
they've been thinking about this for way
longer than we have synthetic data when
you ultimately get down to it is playing
with trains it's taking fake things and
making up rooted in real life stories
about them so when we go back to what I
mentioned at the beginning Frank
Ellison's Delta lines his stage for his
trains doing real things his model
it's completely made up none of these
places really existed they didn't exist
on a map the delta in the Delta lines
was never quite figured out exactly
where that was
his trains were doing real things they
were acting like real trains the place
wasn't very real
to a prototype modeler on the other hand
are they're going to take a real world
place and try and fit it inside of their
basement or they're going to take real
data and try and figure it inside fit
inside of a machine so this is
somebody's model railroad of the Boston
domains Hoosick Falls Brands these are
real towns the track plans are based off
of the real track plans in these towns
um but Rio railroads didn't have to
curve around your boiler and your
lawnmower they didn't have to curve
around anything if you go actually to
the Bullock Museum directly across the
street from here
Bullock Museum's right over there I'm a
geographer if I don't know where North
is they kicked me out of the geography
conferences
um
if you go over there you can actually
see some route maps of railroads and the
worst thing first thing you'll notice
about them is they are very very
straight because railroads do not like
to spend lots of money they're the
startups of the mid-1800s and they're
not going to spend any money for
aesthetic curves around things they want
to get from point A to point B with as
little spend as possible so synthetic
data taking real world things and
fitting it into an abstract space
you can even take something that's
completely made up and create a history
for it this is the fiddle town in
Copperopolis it was a series of cartoons
that showed up in train magazines in the
60s 70s and 80s there is no such thing
the real places called fiddle town and
Copperopolis were both ghost towns
there's nothing here but you can go
through all of these cartoons and read
the real history of them
that is the essence of where we're going
in the future with data science is
making things up but they could be real
they are self-consistent they are data
that makes sense when you compare if you
mix it with real data you couldn't tell
the difference because a lot of our data
is really like this these days this is a
plywood Pacific and to be very honest
this is what most people's model
railroads look like it's a bunch of
track it's down on a table there's some
plywood there's no scenery there's
trains they go and they do things for no
reasons this is like having a CSV with a
bunch of features and they're just
numbers that's how we data scientists
like to think about the world we have
lat Longs they're just numbers no
they're real places I have an identifier
for an event this is a real thing that
real person did this is something where
they bought something they went
somewhere they did something it's not
just numbers there's reality there's a
layout a scenery all surrounding it
it's a Continuum another word that I
keep saying
all the way from obsessive following the
details of real life to abnillo
rejection of those if we data scientists
are going to be continuing in the future
we're going to be the ones deciding
where our models live in this continuum
because let me tell you we are not in a
good place right now we are way out over
our skis there are a lot of promises out
there about things like large language
models in the World At Large is noticing
them and you know what When The World At
Large notices things that we do and
starts imagining Futures where
that we can't back up well that's how we
get an AI winter I really don't want
that you know what they're noticing
right now
this is the uh alleghemy family survey
tool it's being used right now by
governments in Pennsylvania and even
though people have worked really really
hard to make models like this be as
uncorrelated as possible with uh
features that they don't want to track
things like gender race
uh income guess what that's sleeped in
there it's real and it's discriminating
against people right now courts have
ordered them to stop using these bottles
the things that we make well they
reflect back in the world on real people
chat GPT I asked it to go make write me
a python uh function on what would make
a good data science candidate
this is out there it is live now this is
not an abstract problem
you could do this
that's all I'm going to say about that
so
we're about to go out and break into
networking sessions and have lots of
conversations and ultimately my job with
this talk is to prime the pump and jump
start those conversations and I am
certain that some of you in here in fact
if I did my job right everyone in this
room should disagree with something in
this talk if you agreed with everything
I have failed so
the points data science is maturing
we're certain we're a 60 year old
industry but we've really kicked it into
gear over the last 15 years and it is no
longer the data scientist is Select star
from data jobs we are part of an
ecosystem and we need to move Beyond
being the heroes to being part of a team
and our role my proposal is our role in
that team is to be the managers of the
data and the folks who think about the
whole how the whole dang thing goes
together artists if you will
our job is to make decisions about what
our models are made from and it's
important for us to remember that our
models are not reality they're
reflections of reality and because of
that nothing in them guarantees that the
things we do are right that we are as an
industry very comfortable with things
like error bars the outside world is not
remember we are nerds
we need to make our decisions
deliberately we need to actually think
about why this data is in systems what
does it really mean what does it connect
to what do these two pieces of data
actually mean together they can bring
information that doesn't exist in the
model
in each individual data set and combined
there's now information there that
didn't exist before
and finally if we're the managers of
data we should be editing it we should
be taking a look at what our data how
our data interacts back with the world
we should be our data should be the
change that we want to see in the world
I'm especially worried about this with
large language models that are extremely
hungry for data and they just feed and
feed and feed you have to pump
everything into them to be able to get
things to come out and that means we are
feeding all of humanity into them and
quite frankly a lot of humanity is
um it's going to be really interesting
to see now that we have large language
models that write text because a lot of
these things feed on all the text that
they get and that means we're about to
get an aura Boris the models are going
to start training on themselves and I
don't think any of us know what's going
to start happening when that that starts
and honestly it's probably started
already
finally last and honestly least
model railroading is fun
I am Peter lens I am a data science
consultant and let's have your questions
[Music]